the lady of Winterfell except for the
I was never going to be as good a lady
as you please make father say yes son
sir please please is there anything I
ever wanted
how do you answer these charges Lord
Baelish
there's a trace of the White Walkers
the White Walkers have been gone for
thousands of years so he was like
your daughter will do well captain such
a beauty shouldn't stay hidden up here
forever the rest of them you can kill in
any order you see fit
abstain we answer the please - umbrella
- please shut up I'm the only one you
have left our children are gone her
father is gone it's just me and you now
it is true what they say about the
northern girls it's almost a relief to
confront a comfortable familiar monster
like my sister
but they always welcome on the wall now
bastard was ever refused to see their so
take me with you when you go back John
father will let me if you ask him I know
he will
Lord Tyrion tells me a million people
live in this city they're about to
become a million more soldiers in the
army of the dead there's our bride-to-be
I'm grateful for your loyalty
but my dragon died so that we could be
here because it's also nothing then he
died for nothing